[Music]
oh that's totally given but fun that's a
turkey getting butt-fucked I know what I
know what I took you get his butt [ __ ]
sound like you're getting but [ __ ] you
said trip and [ __ ] parrot but
I'm gonna be seen for like a head back
to a la so uh this is what it looks like
but it's been roughly about two weeks as
we've been in Hawaii and I think I'm
ready to get back and do some work you
know work on that channel is how to put
out content for you guys so it's been
it's been fun I know a lot of you guys
don't really understand the concept of
vacation or well I think people from
where I grew up or kind of like they're
the class I guess quote-unquote that I
was in like vacation isn't something
that we really think too much about we
just think about working at work until
we die but honestly when you stay in the
room and you just create content you're
looking for the next biggest thing to do
when you're working on yourself so much
that sometimes it's hard to kind of tell
yourself that you deserve a break it has
been a very interesting year trying to
create content that kind of makes me
happy versus what everybody else wants
to do which I understand that is a very
hard concept for you guys to understand
a lot of the times you create content
based on what's going to be hot next
what everybody else wants rather than
what you want and yet and YouTube that's
how you do it that's how you get popular
you take things that everybody else
wants a scene you do it testings that do
there's ten things that do that you know
I mean the next hot topics you talk
about it and you get big on that how
were those kind of cuts dozen less and
to be honest with you at the end of the
day I didn't get into this game because
I wanted to you know cater to what
everybody else wanted to do I wanted to
create art and create content that
related to me then maybe you guys still
relate to - so my batteries are charged
I'm ready to go back home and ready to
kind of soak this in feel maybe I'm solo
but it's taking me use to me
hey you ain't gotta listen to me
but Pauline I guess he's just a mini
pain we are at the airport on our way
back to LA so we're gonna have a layover
thing going in Honolulu or a waffle I'm
sorry actually both but
what today is
today's Gio's birthday
[Applause]
buta so we're out here in a on a little
airport we're trying to get our [ __ ]
checked in there ready to go in every
time we do that we get the same answer
sit down to relax bro sit down relax
you have cancer sit down relax bullet
won't sit down relax I want y'all to
notice the color of Bart's neck there
you go making butt crack because Lord I
know that is hard but about to do may
your emotions get the best of you and
you cried or you've cried but tell me
what's the use when I'll be right here
waiting
[Music]